I understand your perspective
completely, and I've been you've
explained it very well. But when I look
at things objectively, I think they were
looking for a reason to be angry. They
were angry at what happened. Everyone
was angry. Nobody was was okay with it.
Everyone was angry. It was a sick thing
to do. So, when it came out, the
misinformation from the Russians, let's
say fake or whatever it might be, people
were looking for a reason to be angry at
somebody. Who are we angry at? Who did
it? Was it this person? Was it that
person?
in Muslims. Why do they
Do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities? Every
single one of these speakers have taken
the same program with brother Muhammad
Arshad. Muhammad Arshad has helped
develop all of us. It is it's extremely
beneficial to do this course. Definitely
recommend this course.
What's happened was horrific. My
daughter is seven. I can't even let
alone fathom
what my daughter, if that was my
daughter, in that
uh
dance club,
just her, can't defend herself,
a crazy deranged man with a knife
stabbing people around, she's going to
be the next. I wouldn't want to be in
her position, let alone
me as a father knowing my daughter was
going through that and I couldn't be
there for her. Yeah. It's I cannot even
put it into words what the family's
going through. Yeah.
So, I know what's happened is very
disgusting. But to me, what is more
sickening is when people take advantage
of these things that happen and use it
for their own agenda. Yeah. Now, if the
far right didn't have, which I'm telling
you that their hate for Islam is greater
than the love for those girls, they
would have said, "Hold on a second. We
don't even know what's going on.
Let's wait and see."
Tommy Robinson didn't do that. The far
right didn't do that. The first thing
they did was what? The red trick of
indirect incitement of what? He was a
Muslim that came on a boat that Look,
brother, where did you get that from?
Why Where is it automatically that if
your coffee is flipping cold, it's the
Muslims? It's like ISIS. They were
claiming responsibility for everything.
So much so, once I burned my toast and I
said, "It must be ISIS." It cannot be
any other one else. No, no, brother does
cuz for some reason, they always claim
responsibility. So, when I look at the
far right, right, yeah, and I look at
these individuals, I'm saying how sick
in sick in the head you have to be that
you are attacking a mosque. You haven't
verified any information. And then what
does Tommy Robinson do? He does a video
trying to give, you know, a bit of cuz
cuz you know it's going to backfire. He
realizes it's not a Muslim. But then he
goes and attaches that story of the
young girls and goes, "Yeah, but there
are Muslims who are walking around with
knives." And why did you have to bring a
Muslim into the story? What's Why does
there have to be a correlation? It's
like Daily Mail. They talk about a
story, for example, about um migrants.
And they take a picture of three hijabi
women going doing shopping in Oxford
Street. Yeah, yeah, yeah. The The
picture they're trying to put in your
head is the following, subconsciously,
migrants, evil, bad.
Just remember these hijabis. Remember
these women in veils.
This is what we're dealing with. And the
thing is, look, as much as you feared
for your life when ISIS was
doing madness,
I sometimes fear walking with my wife.
I'm with my children. I don't know what
idiot is going to come with what
brainwashed ideology that he's watched
to come harm me. Look, I don't mind me.
My family or my kids. So, that's the
fear I'm living in as much as you are.
We're both in the same category, me and
you. You're an innocent person. Right, I
I don't know what you do. You work, you
study. Yeah, yeah, I work. I study.
Exactly. You've got a wife, girlfriend.
Yeah. Exactly. You have kids. Yeah.
Same. Imagine you're walking down the
road and you're thinking, "Which maniac
Muslim brainwashed ISIS member is going
to think I'm a legitimate target and
attack me?" And I'm in the same boat
thinking, "Which idiot far right
scumbag who's watching Tommy Robinson
going to come and kill Me and you are on
this side of the boat. Yeah. No, we are.
I agree. No, I completely agree. But
it's just to me,
you've got to assume I try and look at
it objectively. I know there's obviously
I understand your perspective
completely, and I've been you've
explained it very well. But when I look
at things objectively, I think they were
looking for a reason to be angry. They
were angry at what happened. Everyone
was angry. Nobody was was okay with it.
Everyone was angry. It was a sick thing
to do. So, when it came out, the
misinformation from the Russians, let's
say fake or whatever it might be, people
were looking for a reason to be angry at
somebody. Who are we angry at? Who did
it? Was it this person? Was it that
person?
in Muslims. Why do they
Okay. So, so there are people out there
in the far right, and I agree, and they
will look Say, for example, it turned
out to be a Christian or it turned out
to be someone that wasn't Muslim.
And it when it was a Christian. Well, he
was Christian. He was found. We don't
know if he was actually a He He used to
go to the church.
He used to Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, no. Look, this is this issue. He
was a Christian. No, this is a this is
the point. Yeah, yeah. When a Muslim
does something bad, the far right
automatically label it and connect it to
Islam.
I agree. I agree.
When when the Grenfell Tow Grenfell
Towers were burning, Yeah. the Muslims
were coming from early morning prayers
from first Ramadan. Yeah. So, they were
the reason why they woke up the
neighbors to save their lives. When we
would come and say, "Look, Muslims did
something good," they would say, "Why
did you have to bring Islam into that?"
I'm like, "So, when it's bad, it's
Islam, but when it's good, it's not
Islam." So, what I'm saying is that
person was a churchgoing They're from
Rwanda. 97% of the population
what you say, too. He's going to He used
to go to church. Okay, look. The The The
point I'm saying is this. When I say
he's a churchgoing individual, Yeah.
people know what I'm saying cuz I don't
I we suffer from that. People label this
individual he went to a mosque. His
religion has got nothing to do with it.
no. I agree. But why is it when it's a
Muslim, his religion has got something
to do with it? That's my point. That's
why I'm saying he's a churchgoing No,
no. I I understand. Like I said, I think
the far right looking for a reason to be
angry at the Muslims. And again, I
completely understand what you're saying
with that. But you've got to also
understand that it came out and people
generally believe this was the case.
Now, if I was to say, and again, I'm not
going to start making wild stories that
never happened, but say if a Christian
was to go and attack a Muslim family,
for example, and kill innocent Muslim
children, what would your reaction be?
You would be angry. Of course you I I'll
be angry in that situation. You would be
very angry. You would assume me. And
there would be people out there I I
can't generalize. No, no, no. I
understand that. Of course.
But there there would be people out
there that maybe would do that. Maybe
not you, maybe not people you know. But
there would be people out there that
would do that. And a similar thing has
happened with the far right. And yes, I
know there is an issue with the far
right, like I'm saying. But you got to
understand that they were angry, and
they did what they did because they were
angry. And it was because of this
misinformation that was being spread all
over. And it wasn't just in one place.
It was everywhere. And everyone was so
certain. There was videos going up of
people who didn't exist and saying,
"This is the man that did it." There
were fake names. You know, there was all
these stories going around. And of
course, people are going to be angry.
Okay. But I I understand. So, your your
perspective would be they are looking
for it to be a Muslim. They don't want
it to be anyone else. They'd rather be
Muslim.
I I appreciate that. I do. And there are
people out there, just as there are
people like in the example I gave to
you, if it was a Christian family and it
was vice versa, there would be people
that would then go and attack Christian
people.
so so yesterday, two more attacks
happened. Yes. A dow You know, this is
called a dawa table. What we have behind
you is our table where we give invite
people to Islam. Yeah. A table like this
was attacked in Liverpool Street. Now,
it's very clear that he was not a
Muslim. Why are there protests being
demonstrated now? And they are attacking
Muslims. So, I'm trying to understand
That's a good question. No, no, but the
point is this though, but it shows you
they don't care. They just want Look, if
they could, if they could, they would
somehow magically blame him to be a
Muslim. So, where is this obsession
coming with Muslims? Because the thing
is to me is the only people should I say
a state that you cannot criticize is
Israel, Zionists. When they talk about
freedom of speech, there's any
particular group that you cannot talk is
is is Zionists. You cannot talk about
Israel.
Tommy Robinson is directly being funded
by Zionism. Directly being funded. So,
the question I ask ask is the following.
That's why I believe if they had a time
machine and they went back and gave
Tommy Robinson and Paul Golding two
options,
"Go back in time, the girls will be
never be killed. Second option, they
will be killed, but the perpetrator will
be a Muslim." I swear to God, this sick
man would say,
"I'll rather go back because you know
why? It helps our agenda to get rid of
Muslims. If we're going to lose three
girls, let it be so." This is what I
believe. You know why? Because it
doesn't come from me. Caylan Robinson,
who used to work for Tommy Robinson,
told me clearly, I don't know if you
know me. I went to one of his march,
Tommy Robinson's march, and we got
attacked. I don't know if you know.
Vaguely. Okay. So, so yeah, we got we
got attacked. Freedom of speech. Yeah,
okay. Okay. Okay, yeah, it was freedom
of speech. Yeah. So, um
he said to me, "Anytime a terrorist
attack will happen, Tommy Robinson will
get happy." That's coming from an
insider. Meaning what? How sick do you
have to be that you are joy you are
happy that a group of innocent men,
women, and children like yourself were
killed? Why? Because it supports your
agenda. Then now do you understand,
Ryan, when I say his hatred to Islam is
than his love for his people?
No. That's where I'm coming from. You
might disagree. And I totally agree.
Yeah, yeah,
that's where I'm coming from. I I
personally can't accept that Tommy
Robinson, although Then why would he get
happy over it
when he hears, "Oh, who was it? It was
Muslims." Okay, he's happy. Have you
ever ever seen him rejoice about people
being killed by Muslims?
I I I I I have direct I have direct
evidence from Caylan Robinson who told
me he's worked with Tommy Robinson, and
they he was staunch He was really,
really close with Tommy Robinson, yeah.
to arrange the events, Lucy Caylan
Robinson, and George. He said to me with
his own mouth. He said, "When a
terrorist attack happens, Tommy Robinson
will get happy. If this is true, this is
not saying that this man is a sicko." If
it's true,
he's a sicko. And I believe it's true
because I didn't pay Caylan Robinson. He
wanted to interview. We had an
interview, and he said this. And I said,
"You know what? I know he did. I know I
have no doubt this man is so sick." You
know why? It's the same with
ISIS. When when certain things happen,
they get happy. You know why? Cuz it
aids their agenda. Cuz they're like, "We
want to attack the Westerners. When the
Westerners attack our countries, Muslims
get aggressive. We can brainwash couple
of idiots and get them into a" It works.
The cycle continues. And who is the one
that gets harmed? Ryan and Ali's family
walking down the road and getting
killed. We are the ones that are
suffering. While Tommy Robinson is
snorting cocaine with the donations that
he took and sleeping with prostitutes.
Yes, and by the way, he's known to beat
his wife up as well. This vile man, he's
the one who's in his nice house in a
jacuzzi, while me and you are bickering
or
fighting each other. This is what's
happening, brother. So, that's what I'm
that's what I'm coming from. And I
believe I have I mean, it's it's clear.
For them to now carry They've got
demonstrations happening, by the way,
all through August, yeah. And we are
being told, "Okay, we got tables that we
open in Leicester Square. Be careful."
Yeah. Why do I have to be careful,
brother? This guy's not even a Muslim.
He's not even a Muslim. What the hell do
you What do you want from us? I think
that's one part I do agree with you on.
Yeah, I don't know why the protest is
continuing even though now we know this
person is not a Muslim. I do agree with
that. They They hate us. They They They
They hate us. I I trust me, they hate
us, right. I mean, what's your stance on
with the far right and what's going on?
Uh I'm not far right.
No, I never said you were. No,
definitely not.
Obviously, I stand for British values,
stand for British culture. However, I
would not For me personally, um I would
never have gone and attacked any mosque
or anything like No, no, we know that.
Yeah. Um you know, especially without
confirming who it is. And even then, I
still wouldn't do it. It's not something
I would do. And uh I think the far right
are
problematic in their own way, but I
think um
They talk They talk about, you know,
what happened in Manchester with the
police officer who kicked that guy's
head, yeah?
Yeah, yeah. I saw the footage where they
were attacking the police officers.
Yeah. Yeah? And to me, I was like,
"Okay."
At the end of the day, we were talking
about They were like, "Oh, look at these
guys. They have a right to get their
heads kicked in. They were hitting
officers." Okay. Firstly, there's no
excuse to kick someone in the head.
Yeah. What they did was wrong for him to
hit the police officer. They should be
get dealt with, yeah? Not in that
manner, but legally, yeah? But now, they
are the ones that are throwing rocks and
about 40 or 45 police officers were
injured. Yeah. So, you see, I don't
understand. When it's a Muslim, kick his
head in.
When the far right attack police
officers, it's okay.
Do you see what I'm saying? The The
point is, why is it the one where you
know what that shows? Dehumanization.
This is what happened in Nazi Germany.
Yeah. Hitler dehumanized Jews to such a
level
that when it took the time came to pull
the trigger, people were ready because
they were seen as cockroaches. They made
them look like they are some insects.
They are violent. This is what happens.
Systematic
way of dehumanizing. And that's the
reason why where you would have
incidents of a Muslim pregnant woman
being attacked, stabbed, acid attacks,
etc. Why? Because of this. And that's
why we're here, to educate people and
tell them, "What's that got to do with
my religion? Grooming gangs." What the
flipping hell has grooming gangs got to
do with Islam? Yeah. I'm trying to
understand me. Look,
young girls, whoever they are, being
groomed, yeah? Do you really think I've
said this before? If I had a white girl
neighbor,
do you really think I'm going to watch a
group of Asians, or whoever the hell
they are, grooming a girl and I'm going
to go, "Oh, it's fine. It's not It's not
one of us."
No. My religion tells me to stop evil
even with my hands. If I cannot, at
least speak out against it, if not hate
it in your heart. So, my religion says,
"These groomers, or whoever they are,
they were using drugs." Not permissible
in Islam. Sex Sex outside of marriage is
not allowed, let alone rape. So, I'm
thinking, "Hold on a second. What
grooming gangs got to do with Islam?"
I'm trying to understand. You don't
know. And there isn't. And then, we look
at pedophilia. Go to Google and write
pedophile. You The most pictures that
will come, you'll see they all look like
Tommy Robinson, middle-aged white man.
They were middle-aged white men. Now, am
I going to come and say, "Oh, I'm I'm
all the white No, why would I
generalize?" There are evil people. In
America, there's a mass shooting nearly
every week. It's some white deranged
individual. Do we come and say, "Oh,
what's the problem? Is it connected to
the Bible?" No, there are scumbags
everywhere. There are evil people
everywhere. We are We're just saying,
"Let's come together and tackle the
evil." But they call evil Islam. Yeah. I
I think it Just to finish this point
before I go as well, I think
the far right will look for any excuse
to be angry at something. Any excuse to
be angry at something. Um
and I think they're already angry.
They're angry people, as we know.
People beat their wives up and then they
listen to the law. Yeah, they listen to
the law. They listen to the law. Wife
beaters.
They're Their team loses a fight and
they're going to take it out on their
wives.
Not all of them. Don't generalize.
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
There's There's There's some There's
some nice ones.
Um so, yeah, as I say, I think the far
right look for any excuse to be angry.
They were given that excuse and they
were angry. It was wrong of them to do
that. Um
and on that note, I'll say thank you for
I thank you, Ryan. It was a pleasure.
You're a very nice young gentleman. Uh
and where's your Here with your wife?
Who you with? Uh just my friend. Name's
Lauren.
Okay, let's give her a Let's give a
shout-out to your girlfriend. Where is
she? What's her name? Lauren.
Lauren Lauren Come Ryan, yeah? What's
her name? Lauren's my sister. Oh, that's
right.
Yeah, we don't want to do that.
What's What's your girlfriend's name?
Lauren. Lauren. Yeah. Lauren, look after
Ryan. He's a young man, as you can see.
You never know, he might accept Islam.
I'm joking.
And I'm I'm I might I might do the
Islamic marriage for you guys. Please
let me know. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm
joking. Yeah, thank you, Ryan. It was a
pleasure, man. Thank you so much. Thank
you. Thank you.